bonjour à tous à la bonne heure de leur
faut dire qu'ici le site est absolument
remarquable
un site inscrit au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco bienvenue à l'abbaye de
fontenay qui nous ouvre ses portes tout
ce matin et comme on a beaucoup de
chance avec vous florence on va aussi
visiter un lieu magique non loin d'ici
nous allons aller alors là je vous donne
un indice regardez cette petite fresque
naturaliste que n'aurait pas boudé
georges louis leclerc comte de buffon
oui nous allons découvrir à la grande
forge de deux fonds en effet à quelques
kilomètres d'ici
si ici on fait les 900 ans de l'abbaye
bien nous on va fêter les 250 ans de la
création de la forge est d'abord resté
avec nous je vous invite à en savoir
plus sur ce lieu exceptionnel avec son
propriétaire ici d'une famille
prestigieuse
il va nous faire découvrir l'abbaye de
fontenay
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hubert hainard bonjour parce qu'internet
merci de nous accueillir dans ce lieu
prestigieux je lisais dans cet endroit
unique au monde
nous sommes dans le cloître qui est la
propriété d'autres familles déjà depuis
plusieurs générations
oui plusieurs tout simplement 200 en
1820 mon aïeul achète la papeterie de
fontenay et 2020 n'est pas très loin
hubert hainard ce lieu inspire au
silence alors c'est tout le paradoxe
parce que ce matin il faut quand même
qu'on parle un tout petit peu de cet
endroit magique pour donner envie à
celles et ceux qui ne connaissent pas
l'abbaye de fontenay de s'y rendre
malgré tout qu'est ce que vous diriez
pour celles et ceux qui ne connaissent
pas l'endroit pour les convaincre de
pousser la porte de l'abbaye et visiter
entre autres le cloître simplement de
pouvoir découvrir un lieu magique ce
croate qui est le coeur de l'abbaye et
qui est l'endroit d'un d'une méditation
d'une sérénité plus tôt total est
aujourd'hui avec cette belle lumière on
le ressent encore plus et nous avons
tant dans notre époque terre trépidante
avons tant besoin de cet instant de
sérénité
oui si l'on s'en tenait par son cloître
vous le produit et vous le dis est venu
là et vous ne ressentirez immédiatement
nous sommes vraiment dans le choeur du
monastère alors tout le monde ne parle
pas forcément le latin pourtant si je
vous dis ora et labora ora et labora le
dire prier et travailler priée c'est le
monastère brayer l endroit où il ya
aussi un travail bien sûr spirituel
tandis que la bora c'est le travail
manuel qui se fera dans la torche
on ira voir la forge un d'ici quelques
minutes mais je reviens vraiment sur ce
lieu est il sur l'abbaye la bille qui a
été vendue à la révolution comme bien
national et transformer un finalement en
papeterie vous le disiez par son premier
acquéreur est aujourd'hui devient un
lieu visitable par des centaines de
milliers de personnes
certainement que le la protection tient
dans certains virages qui est assez
étonnant c'est la transformation de
l'arrêt de la vie religieuse et monacal
en une vie industrielle
et cette ville industrielle à sauver le
bâtiment certes n'a pas sauvé les moines
qui doit quitter mais le bâtiment est
sauvé et la produisent en travaillant
pour produire transmettre un message le
message
motta si le bezzaz des boîtes justement
à propos de messages quand on regarde un
petit peu l'architecturé je suis sûr que
avec nos amis de france 3 vous allez
voir de très très belles images de ce
cloître
on se rend compte de la sobriété
finalement de l'achitecture cistercienne
parce que ici c'est une sorte
d'échangeurs on est un peu sur un
échangeur d'autoroute mais mes de
l'époque si j'ose dire
c'est tout à fait le mot parfois on m'a
pas reparlé poser cette question mais à
quoi sert le poids et je réponds
échangeur
c'est là où l'on se retrouve c'est là où
l'on va d'un point à un autre et c'est
tout à fait le rôle du cloître et ce
rôle du clac vous le voyez travaille
toujours cette même façon alors
aujourd'hui c'est un peu tronquée parce
que finalement il ya très peu de monde
ce matin voilà c'est le hasard qui fait
ça mais normalement c'est le forum donc
c'est vraiment l'endroit où il y a du
monde mais ça pousse quand même à la
milice m
oui certes nous accueillons beaucoup de
visiteurs mais nous sommes très
vigilants pour que les choses se passent
justement avec le respect de l'instant
de tranquillité dans le monastère
c'est pour ça que les jardins jouent
leur rôle aussi mais nous faisons très
attention malgré le nombre de personnes
parce que tout s'écoule très bien car il
ne faut pas cela arrive parfois que le
tourisme tu ce qu'il vient voir ça c'est
très grave il faut faire l'inversé
ce qui est sûr c'est que vous ne
visitera pas ce lieu comme vous pourrez
visiter un lieu branché avec la tablette
avec des choses incroyables sur
informatique vous vous êtes resté
vraiment dormir cistercienne oui mais ce
n'est pas cela pour faire peur au
contraire il faut l'engagé à venir
trouver cette sérénité
je sais que nous la recherchons à notre
époque pouvons dire venez fonte est un
instrument de sérénité venez le tester
ce qui est sûr c'est que ça inspire à la
méditation n'est beaucoup inspiré ce
matin et hubert haenel parce que on va
les retrouver
florence si que les lacs et pas très
loin de chez nous finalement à proximité
de montbard
d'alésia de semur en auxois nous partons
direction la grande forge de buffon pour
retrouver fleurance et puis nous
revenons ici dans la forge avec vous
hubert hainard ici depuis l'abbaye de
fontenay c'est parti pascal pour la
visite de cette grande forge de buffon
avec alix mouny vous êtes la fille de la
propriétaire des lieux qui a hérité de
cet ensemble puis vous occuper aussi
beaucoup de choses ici un de la gestion
la communication bref vous avez pris
cette histoire à mende où vous allez
pouvoir nous raconter qui était ce
monsieur buffon oui alors du coup buffon
donc été un grand personnage xviiie
siècle parce qu'il a il a déjà vécu de
1768 à 10 788 donc il a vécu dont 81 ans
au 18e donc vraiment un rebond
représentants de son siècle et donc
buffon a est surtout connu comme
naturaliste il est aussi connu à paris
comme intendant du jardin du roy
l'actuel muséum d'histoire naturelle
donc un grand scientifique du xviiie il
a produit une espèce de d'encyclopédie
détruit c'est ça ça s'appelle l'histoire
naturelle est en effet c'est une
encyclopédie
c'est grosso modo le pendant des
encyclopédies de diderot et d'alembert
ses contemporains ça me met objets comme
ça le même objectif donc de décrire la
nature de l'histoire naturelle du fonds
décrire la nature souvent les trois
règles
le règne animal végétal et minéral mais
alors qu'est ce qui lui prend sur les
coups de coin à 60 ans oui c'est piqué
de forges
qu'est ce qui lui prend et bien
justement quand on sait qu'il a rédigée
pendant 50 ans est é 100 naturel il
s'est du coup intéressé aux règnes
minéral et il s'est petit à petit
intéressé au minerai de fer qui avait
dans son dans ses terres natales donc il
est né à montbard et à mon bas on avait
du minerai de fer qui étaient connus
depuis est utilisé depuis très longtemps
et donc petit à petit ils s'intéressent
à ce minerai de fer il fait des
expériences et de fil en aiguille il va
commencer à songer à construire sa
propre force
donc là on est dans quelle partie
exactement alors donc ici c'est le
jardin maintenant jardin d'agrément mais
au 18e c'était le potager le potager
parce que donc il ya la veille à parti
fort j'avais la partie logement des
forgerons et il vivait en totale
autarcie donc pour cela bien sûr il
fallait un potager un verger et une
basse cour une ferme qui permettait à
vivre à faire vivre une centaine de
personnes en totale autarcie et il ya ce
bâtiment assez joli derrière vous oui
alors un bâtiment un peu incongru parce
que donc on est dans une forge
là c'est une orangerie une orangerie
c'est plutôt un élément qu'on trouve
près d'un
château donc c'est incongru dans la
forge de buffon alors elle a sa raison
d'être puisque dans la grande cour
d'honneur la cour d' usine
il y avait c'était une courte retraite
très sévère très minéral avec des pavés
jeu sortira tout à l'heure un pour eux
pour l'évoquer mais du coup certaines
ont un peu austère au goût de buffon qui
était un naturaliste et donc il avait
agrémenté sa cour de caisse d'orangers
et de citronniers et voilà ça donne du
standing après l'averse à dire qu'ils
avaient comme toujours son petit côté
amour de la nature voilà et puis aussi
de débats d'apparence de voilà il faut
que ça soit beau c'était quelqu'un de
reconnu à son époque
oui très très connu de connu à travers
l'europe entière il avait fait du jardin
des plantes un une institution
scientifique admirer du coup envié et
imiter à travers tous les pays européens
il était donc très très célèbre très
connue donc c'était aussi un personnage
qui savaient ce qu'ils représentaient
lorsqu'il a construit cette forge à 60
ans donc c'était une forge qui
représentait justement ce personnage et
on va rentrer dans le vif du sujet de la
forge avec votre papa dans la prochaine
séquence pascal merci florence on vous
trouvera évidemment à la grande forge de
buffon parce que voilà il va y avoir des
choses à découvrir forcément et à propos
de découverte huppé renner nous sommes
ici aussi
finalement dans votre forge un petit peu
l'écart du monastère nous sommes tous
ici nous sommes dans ma force donc dans
la force des moines
pour être tout à fait juste et ce qui
est très vrai ce que vous venez de dire
à l'écart des monastères car il y a le
monastère et il y à aller car l'endroit
où l'on travaille de ses mains et c'est
très important
cette position là car elles déterminent
oran est la bonne on voit d'ailleurs à
l'image derrière nous les fourneaux qui
témoigne de l'activité industrielle de
l'époque c'était énorme
ici c'est très grand sa mesure plus de
50 mètres de long la forge mesure 50
mètres de long mais elle et l'indic
justement par sa taille l'évolution de
cette forge qui a commencé certainement
très petit vers le xiiie siècle et puis
qui s'est agrandie et maintenant cette
taille de 50 bêtes a dit
qu'effectivement
c'était pour les moines une véritable
industrie pour ce moment là hubert
hainard votre fils a participé à la
restauration de ce lieu je voudrais qu
on lui rende hommage parce que il n'est
plus là mais son oeuvre demeure il ya
une magnifique arbre à roues quelque
chose d'assez particulier qu'on découvre
ici on se rendant à l'abbaye de fontenay
parce que j'avais réservé si c'est vrai
ce grand douleur d'avoir perdu notre
fils mais qui a créé vraiment là c'est
trop à aubes cette reconstitution du
travail des moines qui a été si bien
fait par ses soins grâce au stick idée
remarquable ville habitude de regrouper
tous les collèges techniques de l'europe
et de montbard pour pouvoir réaliser cet
important très chaud alors il faut dire
que sa vie un tout au long de l'année
ici aujourd'hui c'est un peu particulier
un ce matin pour nous on a fait un petit
peu le ménage on va dire mais est très
bientôt il ya des compagnons qui vont
venir ici le vrai autour de quelques
animations
c'est tout à fait cela et nous pensons
on hamm est mort de notre fils et en la
mémoire de toutes les moines de fontenay
de tous ceux qui ont travaillé là que
tout ce qui est dans cette forge est un
hommage au travail manuel à l'artisanat
et de la vôtre d'ailleurs pris contact
avec les compagnons du devoir et douceur
pensons que cette année va être l'année
d'ouverture de cette forge à des
démonstrations de taille de faire de
pierre de bois tout ce qui est la règle
hubert hainard on va continuer le voyage
j'ai envie de vous emmener vous toutes
et vous tous qui étaient avec nous ce
matin dans votre matinale depuis
l'abbaye de fontenay du côté de même
s'il vous plaît je vous emmène en haute
saône aux forges de paiment histoire de
se rappeler que la région a joué une
véritable une très grande importance
dans l'industrie de l'acier regarder
et
construite en 16 160 sur le site d'un
ancien moulin les forges de paiment ont
traversé plusieurs siècles jusqu'au
début des années 1990 c'est aujourd'hui
un musée vivant animé par des bénévoles
régulièrement lors de visites
cet artisan coutelier forgeron passionné
par ce lieu partage son savoir faire
avec des démonstrations
[Musique]
j'ai commencé quand mes parents
construisent leur maison à redresser des
coûts dans le feu donc c'est vrai qu'à
partir de là on a toujours eu cette
passion avec mon grand frère et on a
continué dans cette voie
moi même j'ai pu visiter le musée il ya
quelques années et voyant un peu la
qualité des des productions ainsi que
des outillages des lieux moi même j'ai
eu envie de participer
c'est comme si tout s'était arrêté hier
les signes d'un travail difficile sont
encore là on imagine l'ambiance
familiale et paternaliste comme souvent
pour une production renommée qui a
évolué au fil du temps ça si tu fais
dizaine quinzaine d'années après la
guerre de trente ans la région
complètement déserté par la population
qui a fui effectivement tout est armé
combattante et le seigneur veut refaire
venir la population donc pour faire
revenir la population il veut créer ici
l'industriel va demander à son roi de
l'époque et philippe iv d'espagne
la franche comté est encore espagnols il
va demander l'autorisation d'ouvrir ici
des forges pourquoi ils demandent au roi
parce que avec les forges à l'époque ont
fait principalement de l'armement et ici
on va faire des boulets de canon
après le 1850 on va arrêter les hauts
fourneaux les hauts fourneaux vont
disparaître et il va falloir attendre un
peu la fin du 19e siècle pour revoir
avoir une nouvelle production qui va
arriver par de la taillanderie la
taillanderie garde grâce à un industriel
qui s'appelle monsieur chrétien qui est
de loi et qui va ici faire l'un de ces
lieux de production de deux outils
coupants à main et parmi les inventions
de cet industriel le fameux ressorts à
lames elle que l'on trouve sur les
sécateurs pantois il s'est vendu dans le
monde entier
rachetée par la municipalité en 1995 le
site des forges est aujourd'hui
préservée avec des perspectives de
développement je pense qu'il peut se
développer et puis être le témoin aussi
d'une histoire importante de la
ferronnerie et y compris à peine mais
aussi un peu partout en haute saône et
dans notre nouvelle région bourgogne
franche comté et je me félicite vraiment
la présence depuis un an ou deux de
forgeron et je pense que des artisans
d'art ont toute leur place ici dans
cette dans ce lieu et pour leur faire
revivre comme comme c'était autrefois
nouvel atout de cet espace le théâtre
des forges animé par une troupe amateur
de souvigné les thèmes qui propose une
programmation éclectique il a commencé à
la le squat et puis avec l'accord de la
mairie même l'aide de la mairie on a pu
en faire ce beau théâtre que vous voyez
maintenant qui en plus sentir l'endorme
puisqu'on il ya eu l'année dernière plus
de 50000 euros de travaux pour le mettre
aux normes et pérenniser ce lieu de
spectacle
toujours avec vous ce matin sur france 3
bourgogne franche comté avec hubert
hainard qui nous accueillent ici à
l'abbaye de fontenay dans cette grande
forge exceptionnel on parlait tout à
l'heure de ces espaces de démonstration
vous êtes en train de mettre en place et
qu'on peut apercevoir maintenant à
l'image très bientôt les compagnons du
devoir seront ici pour de nombreuses
animations certainement de nombreuses
animations et la taille de cette forge
nous permet de séparer par petits
groupes
il pourra peut-être même y avoir à un
emplacement de la forge des forgerons là
vers le marteau mais à un autre
emplacement de la forge un menuisier ou
alors au contraire un tailleur de pierre
ce qui est très important pour fontenay
et qui attire beaucoup de visiteurs
aussi on va parler de choses qui nous
attire tous parce qu'il ya plus de cent
mille personnes qui viennent ici quand
même hein et j'espère que vous en ferez
très bientôt partie grâce à ces quelques
idées qu'on vous donne très modestement
ce matin parce qu'on n'a pas la
prétention en trois quarts d'heure de
pouvoir tout dire sur l'abbaye de
fontenay mais il est très clair que si
vous restez avec nous en donner d'autres
très belles idées tout et qu'on fasse un
petit bond en arrière quand même pour
revenir sur cette forge et sur la vente
de la production de la fourche qui
finalement procuré aux curés pardon à à
l'abbaye des des ressources financières
importantes aux moines ici pour bien
qu'on comprenne très certainement la
forge en deçà grandissant et
l'exploitation en s'agrandissant ont
créé pour les moines des ressources qui
n'était pas celle là au début
n'oublions pas que ce faire de ce
minerai a été découvert dans les bois
alentour et qu'il a fallu déjà
l'extraire le chauffer sur place pour en
descendre la loupe que l'on voit
d'ailleurs ici dans cet atelier dans la
forge
mais c'était qu'un début progressivement
effectivement l'abbaye trompé j'ai
trouvé productrice de produits de barres
de fer qui à ce moment là cette époque
là était tout à fait précieuse et très
certainement à blé l'agrandissement des
ressources de fontenay peut-être
peut-être peut-être d'être un peu à
l'encontre d'une tranquillité pour les
moines
car peut-être que l'abbé commendataires
qui n'a pas été un véritable succès pour
la suite des abbayes vient un peu de cet
agrandissement des ressources de la dei
mais reynard pardonnez moi si nous
trouble ont un petit peu votre
tranquillité ce matin les cirques pour
la bonne cause
en plus on a des oiseaux qui sont en âge
quand une chauve souris à nantes il
passe la matinée je l'espère en tout cas
d'affluence cicolella qui est avec nous
pour ces votre groupe dans le nord
côte-d'or à côté de mon bar au board de
l'armançon à proximité du canal de
bourgogne et hubert et v ner je vous
propose d'aller retrouver du côté de la
grande forge de buffon et j'ai
l'impression qu'on va comprendre comment
ça marche lance ça y est parce qu elle
nous sommes au coeur de la forge nous
allons comprendre comment le métal
surgissent et ici à buffon avec claude
vayssière paume ou donc notre hôte ici
merci de nous accueillir
dégoût qu'il ya des gens derrière nous
en fait toute cette machinerie ici ce
sont des soufflets c'est une
reconstitution qui était fait dans les
années 80 par l'association de
sauvegarde et l'animation de la forge de
buffon de reconstituer les soufflets
donc c'est une simulation du
fonctionnement des soufflets qui était
indispensable pour obtenir l'activation
du haut fourneau et s'essoufflait se
mettait il fallait une semaine pour les
mettre en route et après il fallait il
ne fallait pas les arrêter c'était une
production continue alors vous a soufflé
dans la loire ça soufflait dans le haut
fourneau qui sont dans le haut fourneau
qui se trouve derrière d'un verre ce mur
parce qu'ici le haut fourneau qui a été
détruit ou via le gothard qui est au
dessus dans lequel on versait la matière
première pour obtenir deux raffineries
alors le minerai il fallait les mettre
du charbon de bois des fondants pour
obtenir et de minerais qui venaient de
la région du thivet à ces kilomètres
d'ici un minerai de pas très bonne
qualité harry mais buffon avait
tellement étudier la composition la
structure de son haut fourneau il obtenu
du fer de bonne qualité donc on voit au
dessus des yeux
une trappe ou et se trouvait le godard
le gueulard dans lequel on mettait tout
ce que dit grande gueule oui on mettait
le charbon de bois le minerai les
fondants on active est avec les
soufflets et au bout de douze heures
on signalait attention il faut près près
la coulée et pour peu près la coulée
11ème et non aux est d'abord on prenait
le sable qui était arrivé dans les
stades par l'entrée de l'escalier on
faisait un sillon dans ce sable on le
passait et on ouvrait le gueulard et on
avait une coulée de fonte en fusion
enfin 1200 degrés athena qui avait aussi
des projections et c'est pour ça que les
gens venaient souvent pouvoir assister à
cette comme vulcain en mai le feu on
voyait 1200 degrés c'est kyle shaw et
une tonne toutes les douze heures visée
assistée c'est pour ça qu'on a cet
escalier monumental d'en face exactement
c'est pour ça que l'on appelait ça le
spectacle de buffon il invitait les neuf
à venir assister à la coulée de fonte
toutes les douze heures une coulée il
aimait bien la mise en scène quand même
exactement mais une mise en scène et
c'est joli à bata est-ce que du coup ça
faisait du métal de bonne qualité la
grille de cet escalier été forgé ici la
chrysalide à près de cent cinquante ans
exactement la grande grille de l'entrée
de la forge et étrangers ici elle
fonctionne toujours et les grilles du
muséum d'histoire naturelle ont été
forgés ici par buffon pour le jardin des
plantes
donc on peut dire que c'était une
performance réussie exactement à quel
génie ce bus feront va continuer
d'explorer son domaine pascal je vous
fais confiance florence et je suis
certain que ça va être encore un très
très grand moment comme celui que nous
vivons ensemble avec vous ce matin sur
france 3 bourgogne franche comté pour
une matinale un peu particulière parce
que nous sommes chez dominique et hubert
et narcy jeudi
on est chez vous à la mairie de fontenay
pour un anniversaire vous faites pas vos
900 ans dites moi tous les deux quand
même et puis alors bravo à dominique de
nous avoir accordé quelques instants je
sais que vous avez un emploi du temps
très chargé mais je voulais absolument
vous rencontrer parce que nous sommes
finalement aller dans votre jardin
même si avant c'était un jardin potager
du temps des moines aujourd'hui il a
bien changé on le voit à l'image
on est dans un jardin à la française qui
est classé jardin remarquable depuis
2004 de la voilà devant l'augmentation
des visiteurs ces dernières années nous
avons fait appel à l'architecte
paysagiste peter holmes afin de retracer
les jardins voilà c'était des jardins
potager jardin des simples autrefois et
pitau rome ces dernières années a
transformé les jardins avec rapprocher
votre micro ce sera encore mieux c'est
un petit bout de vent qui nous
accompagnent ce matin plus tard holmes a
transformé ces dernières années cela
fait tout de même une vingtaine d'années
maintenant transformer beaucoup de gazon
d'halle et de l'hydrogène de david yade
viburnum le choisit ya toutes sortes de
plantes
voilà afin d'agrémenter de mettre en
valeur les bâtiments de mettre en valeur
les bâtiments et aussi de protéger un
petit peu notre vie privée
oui parce que vous vivez ici elle arrive
au moses est alors c'était important de
protéger un petit peu ce lieu voilà il
adoucir
je ne dirais pas l'austérité parce que
fontenay est très beau mais
voilà d'adoucir un petit peu notre vie
c'est une vie véritablement magique que
vous avez c'est ici que vous continuez
de passer seul ici j'ai envie de dire
comprenez ça conserve
vous ne faites pas vos 94 printemps
monsieur je pense que saint bernard le
voeu que nous puissions continuer
maintenir les monastères donc il reste
comme je vous le dit le message
peut-être est-ce aussi dominique parce
que vous avez pratiqué la varappe ici je
sais pas si on peut le voir à l'image
mais il ya quelques collines qui sont
non loin de l'abbaye de fontenay quand
vous n'êtes pas en train d'escalader
quelques sauts mais vous vous êtes là où
dans le jardin ici parce que c'est un
jardin l'on veut être sérieux un petit
peu c'est un jardin qui est entretenue
au cordeau il ya combien de personnes
qui entretiennent ce jardin magnifique
il ya actuellement deux jardiniers deux
jardiniers quelquefois on emploie
quelque 1 en stages supplémentaires et
c'est un jardin qui a été vu dans le
monde entier
faut bien le dire grâce au cinéma par
exemple il ya une scène de cyrano de
bergerac qui est en fait ici a confié
marquise des anges plusieurs films ont
été tournés à fontenay les trois
mousquetaires trois mousquetaires oui je
suis zen de ces panneaux
la scène a été tournée dans la profonde
et jardins et c'est vraiment une très
belle fin mais plus on né peut voir
d'enfanter quand les visiteurs arrivent
ici alors évidemment on l'avion quelques
images là depuis quelques minutes que
nous sommes ensemble
le cloître laforge quand on arrive ici
ce qui est surprenant c'est encore une
fois ce ce cadre inquiète assez assez
exceptionnel le carde wilquin le cadre
de fontenay il y à la vie une chose très
intéressante à voir ses gueules
dominique très bien justement disque est
pour elle le jardin de fontenay mais il
était important que l'abbaye passe avant
le jardin il fallait créer un jardin qui
ne gêne pas les pays qui ne gêne pas
l'oeil et c'est ce que nous avons voulu
faire le jardin accompagne l'abbaye mais
ne passe pas avant oui il faut pas
détourner le moine de sa pensée aussi
qu'ils ne voulaient pas que les
sculptures de l'abbaye soit trop bornés
pourrait qu'elle risque à ce moment-là
de détourner le moine de sa prière et
désavoue suivi sept 7 conseils pour que
le jardin soit un accompagnement mais
non pas en avant un jardin exceptionnel
alors certains diront c'est le jardin
des simples c'est pas tout à fait genre
de dessin plus le jardin des simples
aujourd'hui trop difficile à entretenir
c'est très compliqué vous avez lu nos
jardiniers parfois trois évidemment mais
nous ne pouvons pas aller au delà
attention nous avons en charge deux
hectares de toiture
on va parler de tout ce qui nous entoure
parce que effectivement on peut que
survoler d'ailleurs avoir quelques très
belles images
dans quelques minutes quand été réalisés
vu du ciel d'ici la fin de cette
émission je vous le dis parce que ça
c'est une très très belle surprise que
nous vous avons réservé il y en aura
d'autres merci à vous dominique nerfs de
vous être arrêté quelques instants avec
nous je sais que c'est pas facile mais
vous vous l'avez fait pour nous ce poste
en cours pour france 3 et je vous en
remercie la devise la beauté sauvera le
monde me demande pas en latin merci en
tout cas nous continue nous aventure
évidemment avec vous et avec florence
cicolella qui est à côté de mon bar ou
au bord des larmes en sont à proximité
du canal de bourgogne dans le faste de
la grande forge de buffon est une
revenons pour parler de cette époque
épique vous allez comprendre que vous
soyez ou non
fan de yolaine de la bigne il est
certain qu'on a beaucoup d'anniversaires
a fêté en bourgogne et nous les fait ton
ce matin avec vous dans votre matinale
et nous voici de retour avec alix
mounier on parlait avec notre papa dans
la forge des choses fabriquées et fondue
et travailler ici la grille d'entrée en
fait partie oui tout à fait oui on pense
que c'est une des premières fabrications
delà de la forge donc dans les premières
années donc 17 68 69 la grille a été en
effet forgé ici et elle est toujours en
place elle est toujours en place elle
tient toujours au louvre pratiquement
tous les jours donc c'est c'est quand
même du débat de la bonne qualité qu'est
ce que ça veut dire
cette grande entrée très opulente on
croirait en passant que c'est un château
ici bas c'était certainement ce que
buffon voulait faire en effet c'est
quand on arrivait du chemin vous voyez
cette entrée monumentale
on voyait le pigeonnier et ça faisait
justement entre et châteaux et pas du
tout entre et de de forge pas du tout
industriel et on comprend aussi quand on
voit l'orangerie justement dans le
jardin ça fait vraiment des éléments
trésorerie socrates finalement dans une
forge mais néanmoins en plus cette cour
l'avait beaucoup de fonctions qu'est ce
qu'ils t'ont qui se déroulait ici et au
tour donc une grande cour du sinn tout
entouré le bâtiment alors il en manque
deux mais il y avait des bâtiments pour
les étapes pour les bleus qui tiraient
les chariots pour le faire justement qui
était produit dans la forge une sorte de
vitrine pour montrer justement tout le
faire qu'on fabriquait dans la forge et
puis bien sûr les logements des
forgerons du maître de forges et du
régisseur qui vivait donc en famille et
à l'année il avait une vision sociale ou
ce qu on appelle très paternaliste
avant je reste qu ici on pourrais je
sais pas si le terme vraiment de
paternaliste ce serait bon pour l'époque
on en est seulement en 1768 mais en
effet il annonce en tout cas cette cette
fibre là qu'auront les patrons plus tard
au 19ème vraiment une
une vision très social avoir la main
d'oeuvre sur place tout au long de
l'année à voir aussi des futurs forgeron
puisque les garçons qui naissaient ici
étaient avec leur mère dans le potager
jusqu'à 12 ans et dès qu'ils avaient
deux hommes rejoignent et leur père à la
forge pour ainsi apprendre le métier
ça représente combien de personnes tout
ça c'est une centaine de personnes au
18e autant de buffon donc ok vivait ici
en totale autarcie donc ça faisait quand
même un prêt petit village finalement qu
était aussi cette cour et cette histoire
de sidérurgie a duré combien de temps au
final alors la durée une petite centaine
d'années elle s'arrêtait en 1866 à cause
justement d'une inondation qui va
détruire toutes les machines dans la
forge
voilà donc une petite centaine d'années
et puis après ça ça a tourné encore
pendant une cinquantaine d'années en
cimenterie donc une nouvelle activité
industrielle et aujourd'hui vous le
portez donc là l'histoire de ce lieu les
gens généralement réagissent comment s
étonner qu on s y connaissent pas alors
déjà ils connaissent buffon en général
ne connaissent pas l'aspect maîtres de
forges donc surpris ensuite surpris par
la beauté des bâtiments puisqu'on est
dans une forge et pourtant quand on y
est on a pas du tout donc l'impression
d'y être une architecture est très
soigné très bel essai très vert aussi
bien et il serait vert rue maintenant
oui c'était pas le cas au 18e et puis
quand ils savent aussi que du coup ça
fait six générations enfin les parents
sont la cinquième
mais c'est dans le toujours un mais
famille qu'on fait en sorte pas de faire
vivre le monument bah ça plaît aussi
beaucoup aux gens oui eh bien ça nous
plaît aussi beaucoup aussi n'est ce pas
parce qu'alain allait il nous restera
encore une petite séquence alti rendez
vous tout à l'heure au bord de l'eau on
se retrouve à il me tarde de voir
florent cicolella en maillot de bain ça
va être je pense un grand moment mon
avis ce sera pas tout à fait ça bon ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'avec vous ce matin
on vous donne beaucoup d'idées pour
voyager dans votre belle bourgogne
franche comté et c'est pas la présidente
de côte-d'or tourisme qui va me démentir
bienvenue marie claire bonnet vallée
merci d'être avec nous soit entré pour
jour alors c'est vrai que cette année la
côte d'or célèbre 3 anniversaire
exceptionnel
finalement on braque les projecteurs sur
des bijoux du territoire l'événement
s'appelle épique époque ça parle pas
forcément mais derrière ce titre il ya
notamment les 900 ans de l'abbaye de
fontenay où nous sommes accueillis par
son propriétaire monsieur hainard un
site exceptionnel absolument épique
époque épique époque 2018 tout
simplement parce que c'est là que
l'histoire s'écrit c'est au cours de
deux mille ans d'histoire effectivement
deux mille ans d'histoire qu'on fabrique
et la côte d'or
et cette année ce sont trois
anniversaire exceptionnel trois périodes
de l'histoire qui s'offrent à nous et
qui se donne à découvrir alors les 900
ans de l'abbaye de fontenay patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco
les 400 ans de la naissance du
flamboyant compte de bussy-rabutin tout
près d'ici nous sommes dans un mouchoir
de poche
cher monsieur hainard et puis les 250
ans de la grande force de buffon qui est
également tout près de l'abbaye de
fontenay
donc c'est une belle année c'est autant
d'occasions de braquer les projecteurs
sur sur la haute côte-d'or effectivement
on a vu quelques images aériennes de ces
900 ans de l'abbaye de fontenay des 400
ans de la naissance du comte roger de
bussy-rabutin et les 250 ans de la
grande forge de buffon que nous vivons
un avec florent s'y colle et leurs
valets de la retrouver dans quelques
minutes mais c'est vrai que
l'auxois-morvan finalement et le
châtillonnais rayonne grâce à la mise en
valeur de l'offre patrimoniale et moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'elle est très
très riche marie claire oui c'est assez
emblématique et je reviens à cette
appellation des pics époque ce qui est
c'est l'épopée véritablement qu'est
célébré en bourgogne et en haute
côte-d'or à travers différentes époques
c'est l'épopée des celtes dément du bien
et des arvernes qu'on était fédérer par
vercingétorix on a le site d'alésia qui
est également tout près et puis après
l'épopée de ces moines pic précurseur
qui ont fait que la côte-d'or nos
territoires se sont développées c'était
une véritable révolution agricole déjà
en haut moyen-âge et puis derrière nous
avons le siècle des lumières avec buffon
et d'aubenton en encore une fois qu'ils
ont participé au rayonnement de la côte
d'or nous sommes sur un territoire qui
labellise et pour bien qu'on comprenne
on est dans un pays d'art et d'histoire
en risque de faire des
jaloux mais c'est vrai que la bourgogne
franche comté oui regorge de sites
exceptionnels on a la charge
oui quand j'en parle de soleil revient
s'est fait un nom comme pour éclairer
nos propres effectivement en bourgogne
franche comté nous avons huit sites
unesco donc peu de régions peuvent se
targuer de cette distinction et on dit
souvent précisément que la côte d'or est
un pays un de des territoires distingué
dans tous les sens du terme parce qu'on
a une belle campagne
et parce qu'on a la reconnaissance
effectivement d'un certain nombre de
labels d'inscription ou de classement
sur les sites qui sont côte-d'oriens des
lieux exceptionnels des personnages
sensationnel des balades innovantes
naturel où il des offres est essentielle
pour ceux qui sont avec nous et qu'il
faudrait convaincre si tenté qu'il
puisse y en avoir encore ça m'étonnerait
pas ce qu'on visite beaucoup de sites
mais franchement qu'est ce que vous
diriez ce matin alors il faut aller sur
le site balade en bourgogne qui est un
site une application vous pouvez
télécharger qui est gratuite sur tous
nos smartphones vous savez que c'est
effectivement le prolongement de la
découverte nous sommes de grands
itinérant maintenant les visiteurs
aiment à découvrir et à avoir accès à un
contenu intelligent s'agit pas de se
promener il faut se promener
intelligemment et avoir accès au contenu
à de la médiation donc balade en
bourgogne
vous allez plus d'une centaine de balade
partout en côte d'or qui vont vous
donner accès aux sites dont on vient de
parler donc vraiment je crois qu'il faut
être curieux et alessi produit vous le
savez bien et votre voisin nous le
prouve notre région est une terre
d'accueil terre d'accueil aussi pour de
nombreux films on en a parlé tout à
l'heure
ici sur l'abbaye de fontenay moi j'ai
envie de vous montrer la preuve en
couleurs parce que nous nous sommes
invités sur les coulisses d'un tournage
de film
si je vous dit molière à tous les deux
ça vous parle forcément oui mais molière
au château de bussy-rabutin regardez
nous y sommes allés avec vous
comédie qui nous attend diverti madame
votre mari risque à tout jamais de se
voir fermer les portes pour molière
c'est même le début de cinq ans d'enfer
en 764 ce démon vêtus de chair comme le
baptisera l'église catholique joue pour
la première fois son tartuffe la pièce
moque une forme d'intégrisme religieux
qui va de pair avec le ridicule
l'hypocrisie elle connaît un vif succès
mais les dévots se déchaîne et
obtiennent de louis xiv son interdiction
cinq ans molière au mépris de sa vie
puisque l'église catholique va l'amener
à cette bûche et donc de mort au mépris
de sa vie pas se battre pour acquérir le
droit de rire de tout et rire de tout
aujourd'hui ça nous parle puisque à
cause du politiquement correct et de la
bonne conscience on nous empêche de plus
en plus de rayons de tous les sujets
donc c'est quelqu'un de très malin un
molière c'est quelqu'un qui pour la
défense de sa liberté va manipuler le
pouvoir sans que cela ne se rende compte
et grâce à cette stratégie grâce à son
intelligence de jeu il va obtenir gain
de cause et pouvoir rejouer son tartuffe
comme il a écrit sur vingt jours de
tournage 16 ont lieu dans cinq châteaux
bourguignon bussy rabutin en six nuits
sur armançon rosières et en lait entre
la région bourgogne franche comté co
financeurs du film et la production
c'est un échange de bons procédés de
l'argent qui est investi par la région
et re dépensés en fait localement
puisque tout ce qui effraie deux
quotidiens logement des équipes et ses
allocations d'aidé décor est à nouveau
investie dans la région donc on peut
dire que c'est en fait l'année en
gagnant un nouveau succès donc pour le
bureau d'accueil des tournages en df
c'est quand à ce téléfilm il pourrait
être diffusée par france 2 en fin
d'année il s'inscrit dans le même
courant qu'une nouvelle biographie de
molière annoncé pour la même période qui
devrait donner un bon coup de vieux aux
idées reçues sur ce génie à la cg niel
aussi d'être avec vous ce matin
si dans ce lieu sensationnel je crois
que les adjectifs ne manquent
franchement on voit s'il en trouver
d'autres
allez on va se donner trois minutes le
temps peut-être d'aller retrouver
florence s'y connaît la quête en
extérieur sur le côté de la grande forge
avant d'aller peut-être pas plonger faut
pas exagérer mais dans le grand bain il
est question d'histoire d'ô à la grande
forge de but faut regarder
alors pour conclure pascal vos claude
vayssière pour nous emmener ici dans un
endroit pourquoi vous l'aimez
particulièrement cet endroit parce que
c'est le pont qui permettait d'accéder
aux différents ateliers de la forge et
aussi c'est le niveau de l'eau ces
niveaux des trois canaux c'est le bief
essaie d'être au canoë l'instant
particulière oui parce que quand on
fabriquer des barres de fer près donc il
fallait pouvoir les sortir des ateliers
du dernier atelier la fonderie il
fallait donc les charrois trouvait en
très reculées et remonter donc il est
découpé comme sens exact vous permettre
les manoeuvres alors à la fois de
l'autre côté pour accueillir l'eau est
là pour la punition aussi pour que l'eau
s'échappe et puis vous ya toujours cette
architecture assez monumentale quand
même pour une forge
mais ça c'est buffon buffon avec un
décor on sait la fois comme l'ensemble
de la forge c'est esthétique beau et
fonctionnel
bon et puis alors évidemment l'eau
omniprésent très importante pourquoi les
siens battant caen 6 à part l'eau il n'y
a pas de force hydraulique donc sa
puissance hydraulique a pas de forges
donc là il fallait que l'eau arrive dans
les trois canaux ou ya proquin ou trois
bâtiments le canal de la forge kannad
des marteaux ou de l'affinerie et le
canada la fonderie pardon la roue est
arrêté elle est arrêtée parce que les
vieilles et ne fonctionne plus depuis
1990 on a réussi à la faire redémarrer
mais l'axé fossé et l'approvisionnement
en eau le coursier qui conduisait l'eau
depuis le vannage jusqu'à la roue a été
détruit par un incendie
donc il faut refaire à corsier pour
faire une passerelle pour communiquer
classe inouïe pour faire la grande roue
et puis même le parc des basculer bref
ça fait beaucoup de travaux oui ça fait
beaucoup d'argent
exactement et sans parler du barrage sur
la mention qui aussi lui en très très
très mauvais état et l'armançon c'est
aussi très important dans le dispositif
alors vous avez été récemment inscrit
sur la liste des monuments qui pourrait
bénéficier du loto du patrimoine
racontez nous un petit peu cette
histoire qu'est ce que s'est passé on a
appris par la fondation du patrimoine
sont responsables monsieur bedos est
venu nous voir a dit mais vous avez à
dossier à constituer rapidement on a
comme on est une étude générale qui
venait d'être faite sur l'aménagement de
la grande forge
on lui a transmis le dossier nous a dit
mais j'en vois le dossier stéphane bern
et on a appris qu'on avait été
présélectionné donc stéphane bern à eau
avec l'état constitué dont vous pourrez
acheter des tickets de loto dont dont
les l'argent ira 250 monument il ya un
gros lot il ya aussi des gros lots à
gagner évidemment mais c'est ça le
principe en faire pour sauver le
patrimoine et surtout j'espère que ça va
donner
l'idée certaines personnes dont des
mécènes privés comme actuellement le
mécénat étaient faits au muséum
d'histoire naturelle pour restaurer la
gloriette de buffon qui a été fabriqué
ici et qui se trouve au musée un beau
jardin des plantes à paris
alors on espère que quand même les
mécènes vont passer de paris haïti-
s'intéresser un petit peu à vous en tout
cas bravo bravo pour tout le travail que
vous faites autour de ce lieu que vous
habitez que vous aimez et ça sent et je
pense qu'on a pu faire découvrir au
mieux cette grande forge de buffon je
peux que vous inviter à venir la visiter
en vrai évidemment et ça fait un autre
point commun les cubes et renar qui nous
accueille ce matin ici à l'abbaye de
fontenay parce que on parle et
d'entretien à l'instant
côté de la grande forge et de buffon
j'ai envie de vous demander comment
faites-vous pour entretenir ce lieu pour
le faire vivre aujourd'hui parce que
vous n'avez quasiment pas de ressources
de l'état les ressources de l'état mais
assure existent mais elles ne sont pas
suffisantes comme on peut le penser
pour joindre les deux bouts et pour
joindre comme toute charge de monuments
comme fontenay le millimes
mais c'est nommé scène c'est le visiteur
et nous saluons chaque visiteur il nous
avons besoin du nombre de visiteurs pour
arriver à faire face car il y a deux
aspects dans l'entretien vous laisse
vous avez l'aspect continuelle qui est
toute cette charge d'entretien de chaque
pierre qui va geler de chaque tuile qui
va s'écrouler de chou le jardin à mener
et après il ya les grands travaux et
tout ceci ne peut s'équilibrer qu'avec
l'aide que l'état peut apporter et pas
toujours chaque année bien entendu et
l'aide énorme du visiteur le visiteur
est la base de tout tu nous fais une
confidence hubert hainard le visiteur
est aussi le téléspectateur en tout cas
j'espère donc vous savez quoi il faut le
dire quand même que ça lyon que gérant
les demandes ouvert tous les jours de
l'année chez nous les jours de
l'incroyable ya pas de fermeture
hebdomadaire non il n'y a pas de front
des changements d'horaires en version
mais c'est sûr ça c'est la loi aussi de
l'hospitalité cistercienne on reçoit
toujours on ne dit pas aux pèlerins de
s'en aller on le reçoit
hubert nerfs comme vous le recevez et
que le pèlerin est pressée comme nous le
sommes parfois vous savez en télévision
et que vous n'avez que allé une
vingtaine de secondes pour lui résumé
l'abbaye de fontenay qu'est ce que vous
lui dites
pour résumer la police maintenaient au
point de vue familial je peux résumer
tout simplement
c'est un cas de folie collective web il
ya la famille nous sommes embarqués
depuis 200 ans dans l'histoire nous nous
portons bien merci
mais ont ils et le chemin est dur et
parfois vertigineux mais nous sommes
heureux de continuer dominique et moi
même et dans la mémoire aussi de notre
françois et tout ça dans ce lieu
exceptionnel et magique on ne le dira
jamais assez style sobre
moi j'ai noté quelques quelques phrases
quand même parce que c'est l'archétype
des cisterciens
un sa luminosité sas pictures et
spiritualité oui j'en perds mes mots
donnent un côté unique au monde
visiteurs qui viennent chaque année
moi j'ai envie de vous envoyer un petit
clin d'oeil pour vous remercier de nous
avoir accueillis en tout cas ce matin
ici chez vous à l'abbaye de fontenay
j'ai aussi envie de vous remercier marie
claire bonnet vallée parce que epic
époque ça continue il ya plein
d'événements qui vont se passer chez
nous ah oui il ya plein d'événements de
une date peut-être s'il faut en donner
qu'une le 26 mai avec le lancement
l'inauguration de la saison à fontenay
oui vraiment il va bhl se passer de très
belles choses avec une projection une
projection de film la voix au chapitre
des textes qui seront lus cinéma en
plein air peut-être une adresse de site
internet www.npiquet.com dire ce que abc
super me permet de pouvoir dire à van
damme la présidente
à quel point de leur version de cet
appui de côte-d'or tourisme est
essentielle pour nous merci à vous et
bernard mercier à votre femme dominique
merci à vous d'avoir été avec ne s'est
pas tout à fait terminée on va se
retrouver avec florence pour un dernier
grand or on se retrouve mardi
si le coeur vous en dit évidemment et
continuons la visite ensemble ici à
l'abbaye de fond paix juste après
l'actualité présentée par elsa besoin